Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. By 2009, the Canadian city of Mississauga had been home to Bill and Bridget Harrison for almost four decades. Located in the leafy and peaceful Aaron Mills District, the Harrison's bride and spacious two-story, six-bedroom house was a gathering place for their family and friends.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您手机应用或我们网站上的本集节目说明。到2009年，比尔·哈里森（Bill Harrison）和布里奇特·哈里森（Bridget Harrison）夫妇已经在加拿大密西沙加市居住了近四十年。哈里森夫妇那栋宽敞的六居室双层住宅坐落在绿树成荫、宁静祥和的亚伦米尔斯区（Aaron Mills District），是他们家人和朋友的聚会场所。
Bridget played host to an array of backyard get-togethers and Christmas celebrations. But when Bridget returned to her typically lively and warm home late on Thursday, April 16, 2009, she found it uncharacteristically dark and quiet. 62-year-old Bridget had spent the latter part of the day tied up in a board meeting for work. By the time she pulled into her driveway, it had just ticked past 9pm. She parked her car in the garage and entered her house through an adjoining door, only to discover all the lights inside were off and nothing stirred within.
布里奇特经常在后院举办各种聚会和圣诞庆祝活动。但2009年4月16日星期四深夜，当布里奇特回到她那通常充满活力和温暖的家中时，却发现家里异常昏暗寂静。62岁的布里奇特当天大部分时间都在参加工作董事会会议。当她把车开进车道时，时间刚过晚上9点。她将车停在车库，通过连接门走进屋子，却发现屋里所有的灯都关着，里面毫无动静。
Bridget called out for her husband, Bill, but was met with silence. She began checking each room on the lower half of the house for him. A soft glow emanated from the living room where Bridget found the television playing to no one. On the coffee table in front of it was some neglected half-eaten takeout food. Thinking that Bill might have gone to bed, Bridget headed upstairs to their room, but he wasn't there either. As Bridget made her way back downstairs, something caught her eye.
布里奇特呼唤她的丈夫比尔，但无人应答。她开始检查楼下每个房间寻找他。客厅里透出一丝微弱的光，布里奇特发现电视开着，却空无一人。面前的咖啡桌上放着一些没吃完的外卖。布里奇特以为比尔可能已经睡了，便上楼去他们的卧室，但他也不在那里。当布里奇特走回楼下时，有什么东西引起了她的注意。
The door to the powder room at the left of the staircase was closed. Bridget tried the handle. It was locked from the inside. She retrieved a pin and used it to pick the lock. Inside, Bill's body lay slumped against the far wall, wedged between the toilet and the door. Most responders gained access to the powder room, where they immediately pronounced to Bill Harrison dead.
楼梯左侧化妆室的门关着。布里奇特试了试把手，门从里面反锁了。她找来一根别针，用它撬开了锁。屋内，比尔的尸体瘫倒在远处的墙边，夹在马桶和门之间。大多数救援人员进入化妆室后，立即宣布比尔·哈里森已经死亡。
As there was no overt evidence of foul play, police at the scene believed that Bill had died from natural causes. A coroner was summoned to the Harrison home, as sudden death cases required their input to formally rule out the possibility of a homicide. When a coroner viewed Bill's body in situ, he noticed faint bruising on Bill's forehead and nose. There were also two linear red marks around Bill's throat that were believed to have been caused by a box-gull chain he wore around his neck.
由于没有明显的他杀迹象，现场警察认为比尔是自然死亡。验尸官被传唤到哈里森家，因为猝死案件需要他们的介入以正式排除他杀的可能性。当验尸官在现场查看比尔的尸体时，他注意到比尔的前额和鼻子上有一些淡淡的淤青。比尔喉咙周围还有两道线状红痕，据信是由他脖子上戴的盒式链条造成的。
The coroner ultimately agreed that Bill Harrison's cause of death appeared to be natural and didn't require any further police involvement. An autopsy was performed to determine why Bill had died. Given the coroner's thoughts on the matter, the autopsy wasn't intended to uncover evidence for a police investigation or any subsequent prosecution. It was performed by a regular pathologist, whose knowledge was based in seeking the cause and effect of diseases. The pathologist performing Bill's autopsy discovered another relatively serious bruise
验尸官最终同意比尔·哈里森的死因似乎是自然死亡，不需要警方进一步介入。随后进行了尸检以确定比尔的死因。鉴于验尸官对此事的看法，尸检并非旨在为警方调查或随后的起诉寻找证据。尸检由一名普通病理学家进行，其知识基础在于寻求疾病的因果关系。进行比尔尸检的病理学家发现了另一处相对严重的淤青，
at the front of Bill's scalp. As there was no trauma to the brain or skull, the pathologist noted the bruising was compatible with the victim striking his head during a sudden collapse. It was also discovered that Bill's sternum, a T-shaped vertical bone in the central part of the chest, was broken. Where that Bill's death was not being viewed as suspicious, the pathologist theorized that Bill's body had struck the powder room's sink mid-fall, causing the fracture and bruising. In his report, the pathologist concluded that Bill had suffered from acute cardiac arrhythmia,
位于比尔头皮的前部。由于大脑或头骨没有受到创伤，病理学家指出，淤青与受害者在突然倒下时撞到头部的情况相符。此外还发现比尔的胸骨（胸部中央的T形垂直骨骼）骨折了。由于比尔的死亡未被视为可疑，病理学家推测比尔的身体在倒下过程中撞到了化妆室的洗手池，导致了骨折和淤青。在报告中，病理学家得出结论，比尔患有急性心律失常，
an irregular heartbeat that can have fatal results. Bill Harrison's death was officially ruled the result of natural causes, and his case was closed. Bridget Harrison had lost her husband of 40 years. Bridget was raised in London, Ontario, where she had found success as an actress. It was backstage during one of her theatre shows where she met Bill, who worked in the production's costume department. Naturally calm, wise and level-headed, Bill complimented Bridget's more passionate and
这是一种可能导致致命后果的心律不齐。比尔·哈里森的死被正式裁定为自然原因，案件随之结案。布里奇特·哈里森失去了与她相伴40年的丈夫。布里奇特在安大略省伦敦市长大，曾是一名成功的演员。她是在一次戏剧演出的后台遇到了在服装部门工作的比尔。比尔天性冷静、睿智且头脑清醒，与布里奇特更热情、
fiery personality. The pair married in 1969 and moved to Mississauga, where Bridget began a new career in education. As a teacher, she was beloved by colleagues and students alike. A determined visionary and engaging mentor, Bridget was promoted into greater roles. She rose steadily through the ranks before earning her current position working directly with Ontario's Minister of Education. Bill found his footing in sales and management. The Harrison's relationship wasn't without hardships.
火爆的性格形成了互补。两人于1969年结婚并搬到密西沙加，布里奇特在那里开始了教育事业的新篇章。作为一名教师，她深受同事和学生的爱戴。作为一名坚定的梦想家和引人入胜的导师，布里奇特获得了晋升。她稳步晋升，最终获得了目前直接为安大略省教育部长工作的职位。比尔则在销售和管理领域站稳了脚跟。哈里森夫妇的关系并非没有困难。
Bill was black and Bridget was white. As a result, they endured judgement from outsiders for being a, quote, mixed race couple. Bill and Bridget rose above the bigotry to become an inseparable team known for their warmth and generosity. In 1973, upon learning they were unable to conceive children, the couple adopted a six-month-old black boy named Caleb. Described as a little rascal, Caleb's cheekiness and curiosity kept the Harrison's on their toes, but they were nevertheless happy with the life they had fostered together.
比尔是黑人，布里奇特是白人。因此，他们忍受了外界对他们作为所谓的“跨种族夫妇”的评判。比尔和布里奇特超越了偏见，成为了一对以热情和慷慨著称的密不可分的搭档。1973年，在得知无法生育后，这对夫妇收养了一个名叫凯莱布（Caleb）的六个月大的黑人男孩。凯莱布被形容为一个“小淘气”，他的顽皮和好奇心让哈里森夫妇时刻保持警惕，但他们对共同营造的生活感到幸福。
After Bill's unexpected death, Bridget found herself alone in their grand family house. The now 40-year-old Caleb Harrison moved in to offer his grieving mother some companionship. The move proved beneficial to Caleb, who had recently been released from prison and needed a place to live. He also had two children under the age of 10. Bridget loved her grandchildren and found solace in their joyful presence. However, it wasn't long before tension arose between Bridget and Caleb. Without Bill, who was described as the family's rock and peacekeeper, the two argued often.
比尔意外去世后，布里奇特发现自己独自住在他们宏伟的家庭住宅里。现年40岁的凯莱布·哈里森搬进来，为悲痛的母亲提供陪伴。这次搬迁对刚出狱且需要住所的凯莱布来说是有益的。他还有两个10岁以下的孩子。布里奇特很爱她的孙辈，并从他们快乐的存在中找到了慰藉。然而，没过多久，布里奇特和凯莱布之间就产生了紧张关系。没有了被视为家庭支柱和调解人的比尔，两人经常争吵。
On the afternoon of Wednesday, April 21, 2010, Caleb's eight-year-old son arrived home from school. The Harrison's front door was unlocked. A few steps in, on the tiled floor at the base of the carpeted staircase, lay Bridget Harrison's motionless body. She was face-up with her hands by her sides and her head resting on the bottom step. Emergency services rushed to the scene, only to pronounce Bridget deceased. She had passed away only one meter from the powder room where her husband had died a little
2010年4月21日星期三下午，凯莱布8岁的儿子放学回家。哈里森家的前门没锁。走进几步，在铺着地毯的楼梯底部的瓷砖地板上，躺着布里奇特·哈里森毫无生气的尸体。她面朝上，双手放在身体两侧，头靠在最底层的台阶上。急救人员赶到现场，宣布布里奇特死亡。她去世的地方距离她丈夫一年多前去世的化妆室仅一米之遥。
over a year earlier. Bridget was fully dressed with her shoes on. Her wallet and dye glasses were lying alongside her. This led police to believe she had been getting ready to leave the house when she took a nasty and fatal spill down the stairs. With no signs of forced entry into the Harrison home, a responding officer concluded in his report. All in all, the scene has nothing to indicate foul play or a struggle.
布里奇特穿着整齐，鞋子也穿在脚上。她的钱包和眼镜放在旁边。这让警方认为她当时正准备出门，却在楼梯上摔了一跤，导致了致命后果。由于哈里森家没有强行闯入的迹象，一名出警警官在报告中总结道：总而言之，现场没有任何迹象表明存在他杀或打斗。
The coroner wasn't so sure. Blood vessels in Bridget's eyes and cheeks had burst. There was also bruising and abrasions on her chin and neck, which was hyper-extended as though she had been strangled. Bones in the back of her neck were also broken. This led to the coroner classifying Bridget's death as undetermined. He ordered that her body undergo a full forensic autopsy. At this point, detectives for the homicide bureau should have taken control of Bridget's
验尸官并不确定。布里奇特眼睛和脸颊里的血管破裂了。她的下巴和脖子上也有淤青和擦伤，脖子过度伸展，看起来像是被勒过。她脖子后面的骨头也断了。这导致验尸官将布里奇特的死因定为“未定”。他下令对她的尸体进行全面的法医尸检。此时，凶杀组的侦探本应接管布里奇特的
case. They were aware of it, but ultimately left the investigation to the local division's criminal investigations bureau. They began looking into people who stood to gain from Bridget's death. Raising Caleb was no easy feat for Bill and Bridget Harrison. His school years were difficult. Caleb would lash out at his teachers and test their patience, much to the dismay of Bridget, who herself was a teacher.
案件。他们虽然知情，但最终还是将调查留给了当地分局的刑事调查局。他们开始调查那些可能从布里奇特之死中获益的人。抚养凯莱布对哈里森夫妇来说并非易事。他的学生时代很艰难。凯莱布会冲老师发火并考验他们的耐心，这让身为教师的布里奇特感到非常沮丧。
He was also teased by his peers. It had high expectations for Caleb and wanted him to do well. While the mother and son loved each other, they often clashed over Caleb's behavior. Bill did his best to ease tensions, with his trademark pacificity often acting as a bridge between the quarrelling Bridget and Caleb. The family had a lot of great times together, including interstate trips, but Bridget and Caleb never outgrew their habit of disputing one another. Caleb grew up into a witty young man that others found fun to be around.
他也受到同龄人的嘲笑。布里奇特对凯莱布寄予厚望，希望他能有出息。虽然母子俩彼此相爱，但他们经常因凯莱布的行为而发生冲突。比尔尽其所能缓解紧张局势，他标志性的平和性格经常成为争吵中的布里奇特和凯莱布之间的桥梁。一家人度过了许多美好时光，包括州际旅行，但布里奇特和凯莱布从未改掉互相争吵的习惯。凯莱布成长为一个风趣的年轻人，别人觉得和他在一起很有趣。
Driven like his parents, Caleb entered the workforce immediately after graduating high school. He began working for a shipping and receiving business. As a methodical person who thrived in a routine-based environment, the role suited Caleb. He quickly earned the reputation as a dedicated and hard-working employee. In the year 2000, 27-year-old Caleb crossed paths with 19-year-old Melissa Merritt. Melissa worked behind the counter of a doll store in the sprawling industrial complex where Caleb was employed.
像父母一样有干劲，凯莱布高中毕业后立即进入职场。他开始在一家仓储物流公司工作。作为一个做事有条理、在常规环境中表现出色的人，这个角色很适合凯莱布。他很快赢得了敬业和勤奋员工的声誉。2000年，27岁的凯莱布与19岁的梅丽莎·梅里特（Melissa Merritt）相遇。梅丽莎在凯莱布工作的庞大工业园区内的一家玩偶店柜台后工作。
Melissa found herself drawn to Caleb's outgoing personality and sense of humor. She ended an engagement to pursue a relationship with Caleb. In circumstances that mirrored those of his parents, Caleb was one-half of a mixed-race couple with Melissa, who was white. The pair married within a year. Melissa aspired to be a mother, and Caleb was eager to start a family. Over the next three-and-a-half years, the couple had a son and a daughter together. They settled in a house that was less than an hour's drive from Bill and Bridget.
梅丽莎被凯莱布外向的个性和幽默感所吸引。她结束了一段婚约，转而追求与凯莱布的关系。在与他父母相似的情况下，凯莱布与白人梅丽莎组成了一对跨种族伴侣。两人在一年内结婚。梅丽莎渴望成为母亲，凯莱布也急于组建家庭。在接下来的三年半里，这对夫妇生下了一儿一女。他们定居在一栋距离比尔和布里奇特家不到一小时车程的房子里。
They adored their grandchildren. They helped the pair with their schoolwork and ferried them to their appointments and sports games. Bridget was such a devoted grandmother that she changed her email address to Nana Harrison. Yet, by then, Caleb and Melissa's relationship was strained. Caleb drank heavily, and the couple often argued about finances. In June 2005, Melissa called the police on Caleb. In an affidavit, she revealed,
他们非常疼爱孙辈。他们帮助孩子们完成学业，并接送他们参加各种预约和体育比赛。布里奇特是一位如此敬业的祖母，以至于她将自己的电子邮件地址改成了“Nana Harrison”。然而，到那时，凯莱布和梅丽莎的关系已经变得紧张。凯莱布酗酒严重，两人经常为经济问题争吵。2005年6月，梅丽莎因凯莱布报警。在一份宣誓书中，她透露，
Caleb put me in a headlock and hit me repeatedly in the head. Caleb denied the allegations. He claimed that Melissa attacked him first by scratching and hitting him, and his actions were done in self-defense. Caleb was arrested and charged with domestic assault. He spent three nights in jail before receiving bail and a suspended sentence. This incident officially signalled the end of his marriage. Caleb moved back home with his parents.
“凯莱布锁住我的头，反复击打我的头部。”凯莱布否认了这些指控。他声称是梅丽莎先抓挠并击打他，他的行为是出于自卫。凯莱布被捕并被控家庭暴力。他在监狱里待了三个晚上，随后获得保释并被判缓刑。这一事件正式标志着他婚姻的终结。凯莱布搬回了父母家。
And Melissa forbade him from seeing their kids, labelling him an incompetent father. One month later, Caleb went to a keg party. As a condition of his suspended sentence, he wasn't allowed to drink alcohol, so he opted to be a designated driver. He drove his mother's car to the party, picking up several friends along the way. However, during the party, Caleb started drinking. Those closest to Caleb knew that he was devastated to have been separated from his children, and that he used alcohol as a coping mechanism.
梅丽莎禁止他见他们的孩子，称他为不称职的父亲。一个月后，凯莱布去参加了一个派对。作为缓刑条件，他不允许饮酒，所以他选择担任指定司机。他开着母亲的车去参加派对，沿途接了几位朋友。然而，在派对期间，凯莱布开始喝酒。凯莱布身边的人都知道，他因与孩子分离而感到崩溃，并利用酒精作为应对机制。
When the party started winding down at around 3am, Caleb decided to drive home. His friends tried to talk him out of it, but he wouldn't listen. They refused to get in the car with Caleb behind the wheel, so he drove off without them. Caleb was around 10km from his parents' home when his car veered onto the wrong side of the road. He collided head-on with a taxi carrying four passengers. Both vehicles were driving 100km per hour, resulting in a catastrophic crash. Those involved sustained serious injuries, including many broken bones, and one passenger had been scalped. Upon arriving at hospital, 44-year-old taxi driver Michael Raymant's condition deteriorated quickly.
凌晨3点左右，派对接近尾声时，凯莱布决定开车回家。朋友们试图劝阻他，但他不听。他们拒绝坐凯莱布开的车，于是他独自开车离开。凯莱布在距离父母家约10公里处时，车子驶入了逆行车道。他与一辆载有四名乘客的出租车迎面相撞。两辆车当时的时速均为100公里，导致了灾难性的车祸。相关人员受了重伤，包括多处骨折，一名乘客甚至被剥了头皮。到达医院后，44岁的出租车司机迈克尔·雷曼特（Michael Raymant）的情况迅速恶化。
He died from his injuries the following day. Miraculously, everyone else survived. Caleb Harrison was two and a half times over the legal alcohol limit at the time of the collision. He was charged with three counts of impaired driving causing bodily harm, and one count of impaired driving causing death. He was released on bail to a way trial under the condition that he remained living with his parents. A judge allowed Caleb's two children to stay with him at the Harrison residence for two days a week, as well as every second weekend. This did nothing to quell the animosity between Caleb and Melissa. Shortly after his release from hospital, Melissa reported that Caleb had broken into her home and physically assaulted her in the backyard.
他于次日因伤势过重死亡。奇迹般的是，其他所有人都幸存了下来。凯莱布·哈里森在碰撞时体内的酒精含量是法定限值的两倍半。他被控三项酒驾致人身体伤害罪和一项酒驾致人死亡罪。他获准保释等待审判，条件是必须与父母同住。法官允许凯莱布的两个孩子每周在哈里森家住两天，以及每隔一个周末。这并没有平息凯莱布和梅丽莎之间的敌意。出院后不久，梅丽莎报告称凯莱布闯入她的家中，并在后院对他进行了身体攻击。
She also accused him of assaulting their two children whenever they stayed with him at the Harrison home. Ahead of Caleb's upcoming trial, someone began an online petition on Facebook. Although they didn't know the deceased taxi driver, they were furious that Caleb had killed someone as a result of his reckless behaviour. The petition called for signatures in support of Caleb receiving a minimum of five years in prison. Quote, If we can get 100,000 people to join this group, we can present this to the courts to be sure this drunk driver gets a decent sentence. Please help us to ensure a bit of justice is served. A good man lost his life over this.
她还指控他在孩子们住在哈里森家时对他们进行殴打。在凯莱布即将受审之前，有人在Facebook上发起了一份在线请愿书。虽然他们不认识那位已故的出租车司机，但他们对凯莱布因鲁莽行为杀人感到愤怒。请愿书呼吁签名支持凯莱布至少被判入狱五年。引用：“如果我们能让10万人加入这个小组，我们就可以将其提交给法院，确保这个酒驾司机得到应有的惩罚。请帮助我们确保正义得到伸张。一个好人因此失去了生命。”
In the week leading up to the trial, the petition had just over 300 signatures. Caleb Harrison faced court in January 2009. His lawyer argued that Caleb should receive no jail time, stating that Caleb was rehabilitated and incredibly remorseful. Caleb's family and colleagues attested to his good character, describing him as a hard worker and a loving father. While acknowledging that Caleb seemed to be a decent man with many positive attributes, the judge said that the gravity of the offence and the degree of responsibility required incarceration. He sentenced Caleb to 18 months jail with a further two years probation. His licence was also suspended for two years.
在审判前的一周，请愿书获得了300多个签名。凯莱布·哈里森于2009年1月出庭。他的律师辩称凯莱布不应入狱，称凯莱布已经改过自新并深感悔恨。凯莱布的家人和同事证明了他的良好品格，称他是一个勤奋的工人和慈爱的父亲。法官在承认凯莱布似乎是一个拥有许多积极品质的好人的同时，表示犯罪的严重性和责任程度要求监禁。他判处凯莱布18个月监禁，外加两年缓刑。他的驾照也被吊销了两年。
Caleb had only been in prison for a month when his father died unexpectedly. Caleb was given day release to mourn with his family. In June 2009, he was released from prison early for good behaviour, having served just three months. Caleb moved back into his parents' Aaron Mills home to be with his grieving mother. Less than a year later, Bridget was found dead at the bottom of the staircase. Caleb was questioned in relation to his mother's death. While he denied any involvement, the interviewing officer took note of how calm and unaffected Caleb seemed by the sudden loss. Others were interviewed in relation to the case, including Caleb's ex-wife, Melissa Merritt.
凯莱布入狱仅一个月，他的父亲就意外去世了。凯莱布获准暂时出狱与家人哀悼。2009年6月，他因表现良好提前出狱，仅服刑三个月。凯莱布搬回了父母在亚伦米尔斯的家中，陪伴悲痛的母亲。不到一年后，布里奇特被发现死在楼梯底部。凯莱布因母亲的死受到质询。虽然他否认有任何牵连，但采访他的警官注意到凯莱布对突如其来的丧亲之痛表现得非常冷静和无动于衷。其他人也接受了案件相关的采访，包括凯莱布的前妻梅丽莎·梅里特。
Speaking about the domestic violence she experienced from Caleb, Melissa said, He did some pretty serious stuff to me. If we got in an argument, he would not do anything until I turned my back or went to bed. He was sneaky about the way he would assault me, so I know that he has in him a tendency to harm people if they piss him off. She also revealed that Caleb didn't have a good relationship with his mother before clarifying, I'm not in any way pointing fingers, and I'm not saying that's enough to do something to her. Unlike her husband's autopsy, Bridget Harrison's was fronted by a forensic pathologist.
在谈到她从凯莱布那里经历的家庭暴力时，梅丽莎说：“他对我做了一些非常严重的事情。如果我们吵架，他不会做任何事，直到我转过身或上床睡觉。他对我进行攻击的方式很阴险，所以我知道他有在惹恼他时伤害人的倾向。”她还透露，凯莱布在布里奇特去世前与母亲的关系并不好，随后澄清道：“我绝不是在指责谁，也不是说这足以让他对她做出什么事。”与她丈夫的尸检不同，布里奇特·哈里森的尸检由法医病理学家负责。
Their approach to examining a corpse is medical legal, as their findings could form part of a police investigation or criminal prosecutions. As such, they specialize in examining injuries. The forensic pathologist examining Bridget Harrison's body noted that the fractured bones in the rear of her neck were not typically seen in neck compression cases. Marks across her chin and neck could have been the result of her body hitting the stair rail during a fall. There were also no signs of hemorrhaging in Bridget's neck muscles indicative of strangulation. With finding supporting both the fall and strangulation theories,
他们检查尸体的方法是法医性质的，因为他们的发现可能构成警方调查或刑事起诉的一部分。因此，他们专门研究损伤。检查布里奇特·哈里森尸体的法医病理学家指出，她颈部后方的骨折在颈部受压案件中并不常见。下巴和脖子上的痕迹可能是她身体在跌倒时撞到楼梯扶手造成的。布里奇特的颈部肌肉也没有出现表明勒死的出血迹象。由于发现支持跌倒和勒死两种理论，
the forensic pathologist was reluctant to favor either. Instead, Bridget's cause of death was listed as neck injuries. A meeting between different investigative authorities on the incident led to the regional police concluding. At this time, it is unknown how Bridget Harrison suffered these injuries. After two weeks, the investigation into Bridget Harrison's death ended. The case's lead detective concluded, quote, There has been no evidence to suggest Bridget Harrison was the victim of foul play or any criminal act. Caleb Harrison settled in to continue living at his parents' home.
法医病理学家不愿偏袒任何一方。相反，布里奇特的死因被列为“颈部损伤”。不同调查机构就此事件召开会议，导致地区警方得出结论：目前尚不清楚布里奇特·哈里森是如何受到这些伤害的。两周后，对布里奇特·哈里森之死的调查结束。该案的首席侦探总结道：“没有证据表明布里奇特·哈里森是他杀或任何犯罪行为的受害者。”凯莱布·哈里森定居下来，继续住在父母家中。
He secured a job at an electronics company, started a new relationship, retained shared custody of his children, and stayed out of trouble. He told a friend that while he was depressed about his parents' deaths, his two children inspired him to keep going. By August 2013, three years had passed since Bridget Harrison passed away. On the 22nd of that month, Caleb finished work and drove to the local softball field to coach his daughter's softball team. Melissa had custody of the kids that day, so she was there along with her new husband. Afterwards, Caleb drove home alone. He watched television and had a drink before phoning his girlfriend at around 11pm. He then went to bed. Caleb was a light sleeper, so he slept with an eye mask on and also left a fan
他找到了一份电子公司的工作，开始了新的恋情，保留了孩子的共同监护权，并且没有再惹麻烦。他告诉一位朋友，虽然他因父母的去世而感到沮丧，但他的两个孩子激励他继续前进。到2013年8月，布里奇特·哈里森去世已经三年了。当月22日，凯莱布下班后开车去当地的垒球场指导女儿的球队。梅丽莎那天拥有孩子的监护权，所以她和她的新丈夫也在场。之后，凯莱布独自开车回家。他看了电视，喝了一杯酒，然后在晚上11点左右给女朋友打了电话。然后他就上床睡觉了。凯莱布睡眠很浅，所以他戴着眼罩睡觉，还留了一台风扇
running all night to drown out any noise. The next day, Caleb didn't show up for work. Colleagues tried to call his mobile phone, but there was no answer. At around midday, a co-worker drove to the Harrison family home. He was greeted by Caleb's housekeeper. She hadn't seen Caleb in the two hours she'd been at the house, yet she hadn't gotten around to cleaning upstairs where the main bedroom was located. Caleb's colleague headed inside and went up to Caleb's bedroom. The housekeeper followed close behind, whispering repeatedly, I'm scared, I'm scared.
整晚开着以掩盖任何噪音。第二天，凯莱布没有去上班。同事们试图拨打他的手机，但无人接听。中午左右，一位同事开车来到哈里森家。他受到了凯莱布管家的迎接。她在屋里待了两个小时，没见到凯莱布，但还没来得及打扫主卧室所在的楼上。凯莱布的同事走进屋子，上了凯莱布的卧室。管家紧随其后，反复低语：“我害怕，我害怕。”
They reached the end of the hallway and knocked on Caleb's door. There was no response. The pair let themselves in. Caleb was lying in his bed. His blanket was pulled up to his chin and his eye mask was on. He didn't stir when the others called out to him to wake up. 40-year-old Caleb Harrison was dead. Upon arriving at the Harrison house, police were greeted by what appeared to be a robbery gone wrong. Yet, it quickly became clear that something else was at play. The crime was entirely contained in Caleb Harrison's bedroom, where nothing had been stolen. There were also no signs of a break-in. The intruder had the element of surprise,
他们走到走廊尽头，敲了敲凯莱布的门。没有回应。两人推门而入。凯莱布躺在床上。毯子拉到下巴，戴着眼罩。当其他人叫他起床时，他没有动弹。40岁的凯莱布·哈里森已经死了。警方到达哈里森家时，现场看起来像是一起抢劫未遂案。然而，很快就很清楚，还有其他因素在起作用。犯罪完全局限在凯莱布·哈里森的卧室里，那里什么也没被偷。也没有闯入的迹象。入侵者利用了突袭的优势，
striking Caleb as he slept in bed. An altercation ensued, during which a shelving unit had been knocked over. Caleb's knuckles were swollen and there were foreign skin scrapings under his fingernails, showing that he had put up a fight. Yet, his killer had staged the scene by putting Caleb's body back in bed as if he had died in his sleep. An autopsy revealed that the hyoid bone in Caleb's neck was broken and there was damage to the cartilage of his voice box. This, coupled with bruising and abrasions on the exterior of his neck, determined the cause of his death to be strangulation. Caleb was the third and final Harrison family member to die inside the Aaron Mills house within a four-year period. A homicide investigation was finally launched,
在凯莱布熟睡时对他下手。随后发生了争执，期间一个搁架单元被撞倒。凯莱布的指关节肿胀，指甲下有外来的皮肤碎屑，表明他进行了反抗。然而，凶手通过将凯莱布的尸体放回床上，伪造了现场，仿佛他是死于睡梦中。尸检显示，凯莱布颈部的舌骨断裂，喉头软骨受损。这加上他颈部外部的淤青和擦伤，确定他的死因是勒死。凯莱布是四年内死在亚伦米尔斯住宅内的第三位也是最后一位哈里森家族成员。凶杀案调查终于启动，
prompting authorities to reflect on the circumstances surrounding Bill and Bridget's deaths. A detective told the Mississauga News, anything, in absence of an explanation, may seem strange. But there's obviously some very poignant event that happened to one family. To have three sudden deaths occur in the same household is unusual. We would be remiss if we didn't do our due diligence and look at all three deaths in totality. We haven't linked anything, however, everything is on the table. The theory that someone was targeting the Harrison family was one held by their loved ones for years. From the outset, they had trouble accepting that Bill had died from a heart condition.
促使当局反思比尔和布里奇特死亡的情况。一位侦探告诉《密西沙加新闻》：“在没有解释的情况下，任何事情都可能显得奇怪。但显然，一个家庭发生了一些非常令人心酸的事情。在同一个家庭中发生三起猝死是不寻常的。如果我们不尽职调查并全面审视这三起死亡事件，那将是我们的失职。我们还没有将任何事情联系起来，但一切皆有可能。”有人针对哈里森家族的理论，多年来一直被他们的亲人所持有。从一开始，他们就难以接受比尔死于心脏病。
It just didn't make sense for a man who exercised a daily, ate a healthy diet and was physically feared. Even Bridget suspected that something wasn't right about her husband's death. She'd brought up her concerns to police on several occasions, asking why the powder room door was locked from the inside if Bill was home alone at the time. And, why were all the lights off if Bill was up and using the bathroom? By the time investigators acknowledged these questions, it was too late. Bill's body couldn't be assumed for further testing as it had been cremated a week after his death. Bridget's untimely and unexplained death a year later only confirmed suspicions held by her
对于一个每天锻炼、饮食健康且身体强壮的人来说，这根本说不通。甚至布里奇特也怀疑她丈夫的死因不对劲。她曾多次向警方提出担忧，询问如果比尔当时独自在家，化妆室的门为什么会从里面反锁？而且，如果比尔起床并使用洗手间，为什么所有的灯都关着？当调查人员承认这些问题时，已经太晚了。比尔的尸体无法进行进一步测试，因为他在去世一周后就被火化了。一年后布里奇特不合时宜且无法解释的死亡，只会证实了她的
loved ones that a killer was on the loose. They pushed law enforcement to reopen Bill and Bridget's cases. The family was told that their suspicions were not enough. The police wanted proof. The Harrison's loved ones were at a loss. Wasn't it the job of the police to investigate and find said proof? And now Caleb Harrison had been murdered. How could you let this happen? One grieving family member yelled as the Harrison's house was taped off by police for the third time. They couldn't understand why authorities never listened to them. They had even highlighted two suspects, telling police, nobody else has motive. The acrimony between Caleb and his ex-wife, Melissa Merritt, had continued up until his death,
亲人们认为凶手逍遥法外的怀疑。他们敦促执法部门重新调查比尔和布里奇特的案件。家人被告知他们的怀疑还不够。警方想要证据。哈里森的亲人们感到束手无策。难道调查并找到这些证据不是警察的工作吗？现在凯莱布·哈里森也被谋杀了。当哈里森家第三次被警方封锁时，一位悲痛的家庭成员大喊：“你们怎么能让这种事发生？”他们无法理解为什么当局从不听取他们的意见。他们甚至指出了两个嫌疑人，告诉警察：“没有其他人有动机。”凯莱布和他的前妻梅丽莎·梅里特之间的积怨一直持续到他去世，
but there was a lot more to it than Melissa was willing to admit. Shortly after Caleb had been released from hospital following the fatal car crash, Melissa had called police to report that Caleb had broken into her home and physically assaulted her. Police visited the Harrison residence to investigate, only to find that Caleb had broken his leg in the car accident. His leg was in a full cast, and even with the help of crutches, he could hardly walk. There was no way he was capable of the allegations Melissa had made. Regardless, Melissa continued to make several similar allegations around this time. When Caleb finally faced court for the original domestic violence allegation against him,
但事情远比梅丽莎愿意承认的要复杂得多。在凯莱布因致命车祸出院后不久，梅丽莎曾报警称凯莱布闯入她的家中并对他进行了身体攻击。警方前往哈里森家调查，却发现凯莱布在车祸中摔断了腿。他的腿打着厚厚的石膏，即使有拐杖的帮助，他也几乎无法行走。他根本不可能做出梅丽莎所说的那些指控。无论如何，梅丽莎在此期间继续提出几项类似的指控。当凯莱布最终因最初的家庭暴力指控出庭时，
he claimed that Melissa had been deliberately misleading police officers in what he called continued attempts to implicate him in acts of abuse and create suspicion about him. Police felt the same way. One officer had even told detectives, I am 100% convinced that Melissa is making up the whole story. Despite this, Melissa was never charged or disciplined. In October 2005, four months after Melissa and Caleb had separated, Melissa met a man online named Christopher Fattore. At 28 years old, Chris was two years older than Melissa.
他声称梅丽莎一直在蓄意误导警官，他称之为“持续试图将他牵连进虐待行为并制造对他怀疑的企图”。警方也有同感。一名警官甚至告诉侦探：“我100%确信梅丽莎是在编造整个故事。”尽管如此，梅丽莎从未受到指控或纪律处分。2005年10月，在梅丽莎和凯莱布分居四个月后，梅丽莎在网上认识了一个名叫克里斯托弗·法托雷（Christopher Fattore）的男人。28岁的克里斯比梅丽莎大两岁。
The pair were together for just over a year before they held a marriage ceremony. Their union wasn't legally recognized as Melissa hadn't formally divorced from Caleb. Nevertheless, Melissa and Chris settled in to married life. They had four children over the next five years. Chris was a handyman who also occasionally worked as a security guard. It wasn't enough to support his large family, so the couple sought government assistance and loans from family and friends. Even though she struggled to support them, Melissa wanted all six of her children under the one roof. This included her eldest two children she had with Caleb, with whom she shared custody.
两人在一起一年多后举行了婚礼。他们的结合在法律上并不被承认，因为梅丽莎还没有正式与凯莱布离婚。尽管如此，梅丽莎和克里斯还是开始了婚后生活。在接下来的五年里，他们生了四个孩子。克里斯是一名杂工，偶尔也做保安。这不足以养活他的大家庭，所以这对夫妇寻求政府援助和亲友的贷款。尽管她难以维持生计，但梅丽莎希望她的所有六个孩子都住在同一个屋檐下。这包括她与凯莱布所生的两个长子，她与凯莱布共同拥有监护权。
Melissa made five separate claims to the Children's Aid Society, accusing Caleb, Bill and Bridget Harrison of assaulting the two children whenever they stayed at the Harrison residence. To clear her name, Bridget kept a diary of all the interactions her family had with Melissa. She noted the hateful and degrading way that Melissa spoke to Caleb in front of the children. On one occasion, Chris Fattore threatened, You'll burn in hell for the lies you've told. On another, he yelled out of a car window, You'll pay for this, you fucking bastard. The allegations that Caleb, Bill and Bridget Harrison were harming their children were determined
梅丽莎向儿童援助协会提出了五项单独的索赔，指控凯莱布、比尔和布里奇特·哈里森在两个孩子住在哈里森家时对他们进行殴打。为了洗清自己的名声，布里奇特写了一本日记，记录了她家人与梅丽莎的所有互动。她记录了梅丽莎在孩子面前对凯莱布说话时那种可恨和贬低的方式。有一次，克里斯·法托雷威胁道：“你会因为你撒的谎而在地狱里燃烧。”另一次，他从车窗大喊：“你会为此付出代价的，你这个该死的混蛋。”凯莱布、比尔和布里奇特·哈里森正在伤害他们的孩子的指控被确定
to have been completely unfounded. Once again, Melissa Merritt was lying. She had even been coaching her children on what to say to the authorities to support her outlandish claims. To stem the growing animosity between them, a judge ruled that Caleb and Melissa communicate through writing only. It was Chris Fattore who began the online petition calling for Caleb to receive the minimum sentence for his drink driving charges. He wrote, This is Caleb Harrison, the dick that killed someone drinking and driving. He is unfortunately also my wife's ex-husband. Chris had posted a photo of Caleb on which he'd photoshopped devil horns and a speech bubble that read, Give me beer and the keys to mummy's Mercedes.
完全是毫无根据的。梅丽莎·梅里特又一次撒谎了。她甚至一直在指导她的孩子们该对当局说什么，以支持她荒谬的说法。为了遏制他们之间日益增长的敌意，法官裁定凯莱布和梅丽莎只能通过书面方式沟通。正是克里斯·法托雷发起了在线请愿书，呼吁凯莱布因酒驾指控获得最低刑期。他写道：“这是凯莱布·哈里森，那个酒驾杀人的混蛋。他不幸也是我妻子的前夫。”克里斯发布了一张凯莱布的照片，他在照片上用Photoshop加上了恶魔角和一个对话气泡，上面写着：“给我啤酒和妈妈奔驰车的钥匙。”
Chris and Melissa attended Caleb's trial, making faces at the Harrison family in court. Driving past them afterwards with their tongues poking out. When Caleb was sentenced to 18 months in prison, Melissa was certain she would finally receive full custody of their children. But the judge gave her joint custody with Bill and Bridget Harrison, ruling that it was in the best interest for the children to maintain the lifestyle they are used to. Melissa was angry, stating in a subsequent email, If Caleb is not caring for the children, then no one other than myself should be. The day after Bill Harrison was found dead, Bridget went to her grandchildren's school to
克里斯和梅丽莎参加了凯莱布的审判，在法庭上对比尔和布里奇特一家做鬼脸。之后开车经过他们时还吐着舌头。当凯莱布被判入狱18个月时，梅丽莎确信她终于可以获得孩子的完全监护权。但法官给了她与比尔和布里奇特·哈里森的共同监护权，裁定维持孩子们习惯的生活方式符合他们的最大利益。梅丽莎很生气，在随后的电子邮件中写道：“如果凯莱布不照顾孩子，那么除了我之外，没有人应该照顾他们。”比尔·哈里森被发现死亡的第二天，布里奇特去了她孙辈的学校，
check that they were doing okay. The kids weren't there. As part of the shared custody order, Melissa wasn't allowed to withdraw her children from school without a doctor's note. No such note had been given to the school administration. Chris Futore had inexplicably signed the children out at 1pm the previous day. A teacher revealed that Melissa and Caleb's son had excitedly informed his classmates that he was going on a trip with his family. He didn't know where, as his mother was keeping it a surprise. All he knew was that it would take over a day of driving to get there. Upon learning this, Bridget drove to Melissa and Chris's apartment. No one came to the door, which was locked. The blinds were also drawn.
检查他们是否还好。孩子们不在那里。作为共同监护令的一部分，梅丽莎在没有医生证明的情况下不得将孩子从学校接走。学校管理部门没有收到此类证明。克里斯·法托雷在前一天下午1点莫名其妙地签走了孩子。一位老师透露，梅丽莎和凯莱布的儿子兴奋地告诉同学们，他要和家人去旅行。他不知道去哪里，因为他妈妈想给他一个惊喜。他只知道开车去那里需要一天多的时间。得知此事后，布里奇特开车去了梅丽莎和克里斯的公寓。没有人来开门，门锁着。百叶窗也拉上了。
Bridget reported her grandchildren's disappearance to the police. They made queries with Chris Futore's employer who confirmed that Chris had called in sick on the day that Bill Harrison died. He hadn't shown up since. Police gained access to Melissa and Chris's apartment, finding it dark and mostly empty. Days later, Bridget Harrison received an email from Melissa Merritt. In it, Melissa stated that she had fled with her family because she was receiving threatening letters from an unknown party. A letter authored by Melissa and making the same claims was sent to Caleb in prison. It was postmarked April 17, the day after Bill died. When Bill Harrison's funeral was held, his grandchildren were still missing.
布里奇特向警方报告了她孙辈的失踪。他们向克里斯·法托雷的雇主进行了查询，雇主证实克里斯在比尔·哈里森去世的那天请了病假。从那以后他就没出现过。警方进入了梅丽莎和克里斯的公寓，发现里面昏暗且几乎空无一人。几天后，布里奇特·哈里森收到了梅丽莎·梅里特的一封电子邮件。在邮件中，梅丽莎声称她带着家人逃跑了，因为她收到了来自未知方的威胁信。一封由梅丽莎撰写并提出同样主张的信被寄给了监狱里的凯莱布。信的邮戳是4月17日，即比尔去世的第二天。比尔·哈里森举行葬礼时，他的孙辈仍然失踪。
The next day, Bridget was granted sole custody of the children, despite no one knowing where they were. Missing persons' ads were published in newspapers across the country as Bridget sought the help of a private investigator. Two months into the disappearance, Caleb was paroled. Efforts to track Melissa Merritt and Chris Futore had come up dry. By November 2009, Melissa and Chris had been missing for seven months. Approval to seize and review Melissa's banking records was granted, providing a much needed breakthrough. They revealed a transaction in the Canadian province of Nova Scotia, 1300 km east from Mississauga. An arrest warrant was issued and the family were finally uncovered.
第二天，尽管没人知道他们在哪里，布里奇特还是获得了孩子的唯一监护权。随着布里奇特寻求私家侦探的帮助，寻人启事在全国各地的报纸上刊登。失踪两个月后，凯莱布获得假释。追踪梅丽莎·梅里特和克里斯·法托雷的努力均告失败。到2009年11月，梅丽莎和克里斯已经失踪了七个月。扣押和审查梅丽莎银行记录的批准获得通过，提供了急需的突破。他们揭示了在加拿大新斯科舍省的一笔交易，距离密西沙加1300公里。逮捕令发出，一家人终于被发现。
In an effort to go undetected, Melissa had dyed her children's hair and the group were going by different names. Melissa was charged with parental child abduction and she lost access to the two children she shared with Caleb Harrison. They were placed in Caleb's care, who was granted shared custody with his mother, Bridget. Melissa Merritt pleaded guilty and a hearing was set for April 22, 2010. In the lead-up, Bridget Harrison prepared a victim impact statement. She described the seven months her grandchildren were missing as the most desperate of her life. The fact that Melissa and Chris had orchestrated their runaway on the very day Bill had died wasn't lost on Bridget. In her statement, she wrote,
为了不被发现，梅丽莎染了孩子们的头发，他们一行人改用了不同的名字。梅丽莎被控绑架儿童，并失去了与凯莱布·哈里森共同抚养的两个孩子的监护权。他们被安置在凯莱布的照顾下，凯莱布获得了与他母亲布里奇特的共同监护权。梅丽莎·梅里特认罪，听证会定于2010年4月22日举行。在此之前，布里奇特·哈里森准备了一份受害者影响陈述。她将孙辈失踪的七个月描述为她一生中最绝望的时期。梅丽莎和克里斯在比尔去世当天策划逃跑的事实，布里奇特并没有忘记。在她的陈述中，她写道：
Some people believe in coincidences, some do not. Bridget was never able to deliver her victim impact statement. The day before Melissa Merritt's hearing was set to begin, Bridget was found to dead. Melissa was convicted for parental abduction and received 18 months probation. Meanwhile, her ex-husband was growing increasingly suspicious. As detailed in the Toronto Star newspaper, Caleb Harrison told a cousin, There's no way anyone falls down the stairs and ends up in that position. It doesn't look right. It doesn't make sense. Caleb had even aired the same concerns to police during interviews
“有些人相信巧合，有些人不相信。”布里奇特没能发表她的受害者影响陈述。在梅丽莎·梅里特听证会开始的前一天，布里奇特被发现死亡。梅丽莎因绑架儿童被定罪，并被判处18个月缓刑。与此同时，她的前夫越来越怀疑。正如《多伦多星报》所详述的那样，凯莱布·哈里森告诉一位表亲：“没有人会摔下楼梯并以那种姿势躺着。这看起来不对劲。这说不通。”凯莱布甚至在采访中向警方表达了同样的担忧，
following his mother's death. He detailed his rocky history with Melissa while acknowledging the timing of Bridget's death as weird. When asked who he thought was responsible for his mother's death, Caleb replied, I would ask where Melissa and Chris were, personally. When speaking to police about Bridget's death, Melissa Merritt said she was at home babysitting as part of a daycare business she was trying to get up and running. Chris Vitore said he'd spent the day working in his backyard and running errands. Shop surveillance cameras had captured him in town, yet there was a brief time he was unaccounted for. Chris said he had visited Melissa's grandmother to pick up a drum kit.
在他母亲去世后。他详细描述了他与梅丽莎的坎坷历史，同时承认布里奇特死亡的时间点很“奇怪”。当被问及他认为谁应对他母亲的死负责时，凯莱布回答说：“我个人会问梅丽莎和克里斯在哪里。”在向警方谈到布里奇特的死时，梅丽莎·梅里特说她当时在家照顾孩子，这是她试图开展的日托业务的一部分。克里斯·法托雷说他那天在后院工作并跑腿。商店监控摄像头拍到了他在镇上的画面，但有一段时间他的行踪不明。克里斯说他去拜访了梅丽莎的祖母去取一套鼓。
Police never spoke with the woman to confirm this alibi. Melissa worked to implicate Caleb in Bridget's death. In interviews, she referenced Caleb's history of violence against her. Even though it was known to be baseless. Furthermore, Caleb couldn't have killed Bridget. An alibi placed him at work that day. With that, the investigation into Bridget's death was closed. Caleb Harrison received sole custody of his two children in the aftermath of his mother's death, putting his personal feelings aside. In mid-2013, he agreed to a temporary schedule. The children would remain living at the Harrison home, but would now spend every other weekend
警方从未与该女子交谈以证实这一不在场证明。梅丽莎致力于将凯莱布牵连进布里奇特的死亡案中。在采访中，她提到了凯莱布对她有暴力史，尽管众所周知这是毫无根据的。此外，凯莱布不可能杀害布里奇特，因为有不在场证明显示他当天在工作。至此，对布里奇特死因的调查宣告结束。凯莱布·哈里森在母亲去世后获得了两个孩子的唯一监护权，他将个人感情放在一边。2013年中期，他同意了一个临时安排：孩子们将继续住在哈里森家，但每隔一个周末会去
with Melissa and Chris. It wasn't an easy arrangement, as Melissa and Chris had relocated to a rural town 350km from Mississauga. But Caleb was making it work. In August 2013, the agreement was due to end. Melissa wanted shared custody, but Caleb refused. He had several child support demands that Melissa refused to meet. The day before the custody battle was due to reach its conclusion, Caleb Harrison was killed. With Caleb dead, Melissa was given sole custody of their two children. In the paperwork, she described Caleb's death as tragic and shocking, but Caleb's loved ones were convinced she was involved in some way. When Melissa attempted to attend Caleb's wake,
和梅丽莎及克里斯在一起。这并非易事，因为梅丽莎和克里斯已经搬到了距离密西沙加350公里外的一个乡村小镇。但凯莱布一直在努力维持。2013年8月，协议即将到期。梅丽莎想要共同监护权，但凯莱布拒绝了。他提出了几项梅丽莎拒绝满足的子女抚养费要求。在监护权之争即将结束的前一天，凯莱布·哈里森被杀害了。随着凯莱布的死亡，梅丽莎获得了两个孩子的唯一监护权。在文书中，她将凯莱布的死描述为悲剧和令人震惊，但凯莱布的亲人们确信她以某种方式参与其中。当梅丽莎试图参加凯莱布的守灵仪式时，
they turned her away. Both Melissa and Chris maintained that the last time they'd seen Caleb was at the youth softball match they had all attended hours before he was killed. Afterwards, Melissa and Chris ate dinner at a fast food restaurant in a shopping mall. They went home to bed and woke up at 6am. Melissa insisted there was no way that Chris could have snuck out in the middle of the night without waking her. Yet, when presenting this sequence of events to investigators, neither Melissa nor Chris mentioned Walmart. This was significant. An undercover officer had posed as a waste collector to confiscate Melissa and Chris's household rubbish. Sorting through it,
他们把她拒之门外。梅丽莎和克里斯都坚称，他们最后一次见到凯莱布是在他被杀前几小时他们共同参加的青少年垒球比赛上。之后，梅丽莎和克里斯在一家购物中心的快餐店吃了晚饭。他们回家睡觉，并在早上6点醒来。梅丽莎坚称克里斯不可能在半夜溜出去而不吵醒她。然而，当向调查人员陈述这一事件经过时，梅丽莎和克里斯都没有提到沃尔玛。这一点意义重大。一名卧底警察伪装成垃圾收集员，没收了梅丽莎和克里斯的家庭垃圾。在整理垃圾时，
they found a black pair of size 12 running shoes inside a plastic bag. They had been worn, but were otherwise brand new. The shoes were sold exclusively in Walmart, a multinational retail superstore. Investigators obtained records from the Walmart closest to Melissa and Chris's home. Only one size 12 pair of that particular shoe had been sold in the past two months. The sale had occurred mere hours before Caleb Harrison was killed. CCTV footage captured Chris for Torre as he wandered around the store with the shoes in hand. Bank records showed he had made a purchase for the exact amount the shoes cost.
他们在一个塑料袋里发现了一双12码的黑色跑鞋。这双鞋穿过，但除此之外看起来是全新的。这种鞋只在跨国零售超市沃尔玛独家销售。调查人员获得了离梅丽莎和克里斯家最近的沃尔玛的记录。在过去两个月里，该款鞋只售出过一双12码的。这笔交易发生在凯莱布·哈里森被杀前仅仅几个小时。监控录像拍到了克里斯·福托雷手里拿着鞋在店里闲逛的画面。银行记录显示，他进行了一笔金额与鞋价完全一致的消费。
While Melissa and Chris had admitted to eating dinner at that same shopping mall that night, neither mentioned going into Walmart or buying the shoes. Investigators began covertly following Chris for Torre. They watched as he went around town and swooped when he threw away an empty takeaway coffee cup. They'd lifted his DNA from the cup and compared it to the skin scrapings from underneath Caleb Harrison's fingernails. It was a match. A pair of latex gloves that were uncovered in Melissa's and Chris's trash also contained both Chris and Caleb's DNA. Following these major breakthroughs, investigators rigged the
虽然梅丽莎和克里斯承认那天晚上在同一个购物中心吃过晚饭，但两人都没有提到去过沃尔玛或购买过那双鞋。调查人员开始秘密跟踪克里斯·福托雷。他们观察他在城里四处走动，并在他扔掉一个空外卖咖啡杯时迅速行动。他们从杯子上提取了他的DNA，并将其与凯莱布·哈里森指甲下的皮肤碎屑进行了比对。结果吻合。在梅丽莎和克里斯的垃圾中发现的一副乳胶手套也同时含有克里斯和凯莱布的DNA。在取得这些重大突破后，调查人员在
couple's home with covert listening devices. It took five months before they picked up anything significant. Melissa Merritt was heard telling Chris for Torre, you have to realize that the underlying fact of the matter is that you killed Caleb. Chris responded, I know. Authorities executed a search warrant on a trailer belonging to Melissa and Chris. They confiscated a laptop and examined its contents. In the months and weeks leading up to Bridget Harrison's death, someone had typed into a search engine. What if a grandparent has legal custody and they die? How long does it take to die from
这对夫妇的家中安装了秘密监听设备。五个月后，他们才捕捉到重要信息。梅丽莎·梅里特被听到对克里斯·福托雷说：“你必须意识到，事情的根本事实是你杀了凯莱布。”克里斯回答说：“我知道。”当局对梅丽莎和克里斯所属的一辆拖车执行了搜查令。他们没收了一台笔记本电脑并检查了其内容。在布里奇特·哈里森去世前的几个月和几周里，有人在搜索引擎中输入了：“如果祖父母拥有合法监护权而他们去世了会怎样？”“死于
choking? And how long does it take for a person being strangled to pass out? One month before Caleb was killed, someone had searched. Easy ways to kill and get away with it. Melissa Merritt and Chris for Torre were arrested for the first degree murders of Caleb Harrison and Bridget Harrison. After 13 hours of questioning, an exasperated Chris admitted that he didn't like the Harrison's. He spoke of being told horrific stories of how they treated Melissa's children. Adding, It was an awful family. They treated the children like shit and I and Melissa had to live with it every day and I couldn't watch Melissa's attitude and how sorry she was for everything that was going on.
窒息需要多长时间？”以及“一个人被勒死需要多长时间才会昏迷？”在凯莱布被杀前一个月，有人搜索了：“杀人并逃脱惩罚的简单方法。”梅丽莎·梅里特和克里斯·福托雷因一级谋杀凯莱布·哈里森和布里奇特·哈里森而被捕。经过13小时的审讯，愤怒的克里斯承认他不喜欢哈里森一家。他谈到曾被告知关于他们如何对待梅丽莎孩子的可怕故事，并补充说：“那是一个糟糕的家庭。他们像对待垃圾一样对待孩子们，我和梅丽莎每天都必须忍受，我无法看着梅丽莎的态度以及她对所发生的一切感到多么抱歉。”
The interviewing officer then asked Chris, What did you do? I killed Bridget Harrison and Caleb Harrison. How did you kill Bridget? Knocked on her door. She opened the door. I pretended to have a ladder to give to the children. She refused the ladder so I then forced my way into the house and I adopted her. What did you do?
审讯警官随后问克里斯：“你做了什么？”“我杀了布里奇特·哈里森和凯莱布·哈里森。”“你是怎么杀害布里奇特的？”“敲了她的门。她开了门。我假装有一个梯子要给孩子们。她拒绝了梯子，所以我强行闯入屋内，然后我勒死了她。”“你做了什么？”
I hit her a couple of times. I then received it to squeeze her neck. Until she stopped re-regulating on the floor. And as for Caleb, I snuck out in the middle of the night. I also had no idea. I laughed at one there. I caught her to his house. She seemed to go up to the bedroom.
“我打了她几下。然后我开始掐她的脖子。直到她停止在地板上挣扎。至于凯莱布，我半夜溜了出去。我当时也没什么主意。我开车去了他家。她似乎上楼去了卧室。”
I hit him in the chest and when he brought me up, we began to struggle. I threw him into the shelving unit beside his bed. He tried to bribe me with money. I didn't speak to him. I just knocked him to the ground and I proceeded to choke him. Chris told detectives. I'm telling you right now that Melissa Merritt did not know anything until after it was done. The detectives were unconvinced. They placed Chris and Melissa in a room alone together and listened in as the couple started whispering. Chris revealed that he had confessed to Bridget and Caleb's murders in a panic. He told Melissa that he wanted to kill him.
“我打了他的胸口，当他反抗时，我们开始扭打。我把他推向床边的架子。他试图用钱贿赂我。我没理他。我只是把他打倒在地，然后开始掐他。”克里斯告诉侦探：“我现在告诉你，梅丽莎·梅里特在事情做完之前什么都不知道。”侦探们并不相信。他们把克里斯和梅丽莎单独关在一个房间里，并监听这对夫妇开始窃窃私语。克里斯透露，他在恐慌中承认了布里奇特和凯莱布的谋杀案。他告诉梅丽莎，他想杀了他，
He wanted her to get a lesser sentence, explaining, I'm taking the rap for it to give you accessory after the fact. I told them, I told you after they were killed. Melissa asked why. Chris replied, because I want you to get our children. Chris Vittore was charged with two counts of first degree murder. Despite his claims that Melissa was not involved, she faced the same charges. When it came to Bill Harrison, Chris said that out of all the Harrison family, he liked Bill the best. He maintained that he was not responsible for Bill's death.
他想让她获得较轻的判决，解释说：“我是在替你顶罪，好让你被判从犯。我告诉他们，是在他们被杀后我才告诉你的。”梅丽莎问为什么。克里斯回答说：“因为我想让你照顾我们的孩子。”克里斯·福托雷被控两项一级谋杀罪。尽管他声称梅丽莎没有参与，但她面临同样的指控。当提到比尔·哈里森时，克里斯说在所有哈里森家族成员中，他最喜欢比尔。他坚称自己不对比尔的死负责。
Nevertheless, he was also charged with the second degree murder of Bill Harrison. Both Chris and Melissa pleaded not guilty. The couple's joint trial commenced in November 2017. The ugly custody battle between Melissa Merritt and Caleb Harrison formed the basis of the prosecution's case. They told the court that Melissa and Chris thought they stood to inherit millions from the Harrison estate. Chris Vittore recanted his confession at trial, claiming it was coerced. He thought that by taking full blame for the crimes, Melissa would be free to look after their children. While Chris would maintain a not guilty plea when it came to Bill and Bridget's murders,
尽管如此，他还是被控二级谋杀比尔·哈里森。克里斯和梅丽莎均不认罪。这对夫妇的联合审判于2017年11月开始。梅丽莎·梅里特和凯莱布·哈里森之间丑陋的监护权之争构成了检方案件的基础。他们告诉法庭，梅丽莎和克里斯认为他们将从哈里森遗产中继承数百万美元。克里斯·福托雷在审判中撤回了他的供词，声称是被迫的。他认为通过承担所有罪行，梅丽莎就能自由地照顾他们的孩子。虽然克里斯在比尔和布里奇特的谋杀案上坚持不认罪，
he sought to plead guilty to the lesser charge of manslaughter when it came to Caleb. He stated that he had only intended to rough Caleb up and maybe put him in the hospital. The prosecution rejected his plea. They were confident that they had enough evidence to prove Chris killed with intent. The difficulty lay in the case against Melissa Merritt. The evidence against her was circumstantial and her legal team knew it. From their perspective, the prosecution's case at best characterized Melissa as an accessory after the fact. The prosecution argued that Chris wouldn't have committed the murders had he not been compelled to do so by Melissa. It took six hours for the jury to reach a verdict.
但他试图就凯莱布的案件承认较轻的过失杀人罪。他声称他只是想教训一下凯莱布，也许让他住进医院。检方拒绝了他的认罪请求。他们确信有足够的证据证明克里斯是有预谋地杀人。困难在于针对梅丽莎·梅里特的案件。针对她的证据是间接的，她的法律团队很清楚这一点。从他们的角度来看，检方的案件充其量只能将梅丽莎定性为事后从犯。检方辩称，如果不是受到梅丽莎的胁迫，克里斯就不会犯下这些谋杀案。陪审团花了六个小时才达成裁决。
Chris Vittore was found guilty for the murders of Bridget and Caleb Harrison. He was acquitted of Bill Harrison's murder due to a lack of evidence. Melissa Merritt was acquitted of Bridget Harrison's murder as the jury were unable to reach a decision regarding her involvement. For the murder of her ex-husband Caleb Harrison, Melissa was found guilty. Melissa cried as her sentence was delivered. Chris sat close by, stone-faced. Both were handed life sentences with a non-parole period of 25 years. When speaking of the Harrison family, Bill Harrison's sister said, I cannot fathom how people who love to their family, love to their friends and love to their
克里斯·福托雷被判谋杀布里奇特和凯莱布·哈里森罪名成立。由于证据不足，他被判谋杀比尔·哈里森无罪。梅丽莎·梅里特被判谋杀布里奇特·哈里森无罪，因为陪审团无法就她的参与程度达成一致。对于谋杀前夫凯莱布·哈里森，梅丽莎被判有罪。宣判时，梅丽莎哭了。克里斯坐在附近，面无表情。两人都被判处终身监禁，且25年内不得假释。在谈到哈里森一家时，比尔·哈里森的妹妹说：“我无法理解那些热爱家庭、热爱朋友、热爱
community so greatly, could have been dealt such an injustice. We have all suffered from recurring violent nightmares of our loved ones' last moments, and we will never forget that terror that plagued us for years, not knowing which family member might die under suspicious circumstances or when. Addressing the convicted killers, one of Caleb's cousins said, I hope that one day you realise that you destroyed an innocent family at the cost of your own. In 2020, an independent review was launched into why Bill and Bridget Harrison's murders had originally been overlooked. The extended Harrison family welcomed the investigation, saying that Caleb and Bridget might still be alive had Bill's death been investigated properly.
社区的人，怎么会遭受如此不公。我们所有人都因亲人最后时刻的暴力噩梦而反复受折磨，我们将永远不会忘记那些年来困扰我们的恐惧，不知道哪个家庭成员会在可疑的情况下死亡，或者何时死亡。”在对被定罪的杀手讲话时，凯莱布的一位堂兄说：“我希望有一天你们能意识到，你们以牺牲自己的家庭为代价，摧毁了一个无辜的家庭。”2020年，一项独立审查启动，调查比尔和布里奇特·哈里森的谋杀案为何最初被忽视。哈里森家族的大家庭对调查表示欢迎，称如果比尔的死得到妥善调查，凯莱布和布里奇特可能还活着。
The family issued a statement saying they were haunted by lingering questions about the investigative and forensic handling of the case. Some of the review was made public. It highlighted a multitude of police errors, including poor communication, note-taking and coordination of resources. In Bill Harrison's case, a layered neck dissection wasn't performed during his autopsy, even though there were signs of trauma to his throat. The performing pathologist had also failed to uncover any trace of heart abnormalities or heart disease. Yet, he still ruled Bill's death as the result of acute cardiac arrhythmia. The pathologist later reflected,
该家族发表声明称，他们被关于案件调查和法医处理的挥之不去的问题所困扰。部分审查结果已公开。它强调了大量的警察失误，包括沟通不畅、记录不全和资源协调不力。在比尔·哈里森的案件中，尽管他的喉咙有创伤迹象，但在尸检过程中并未进行分层颈部解剖。执行尸检的病理学家也未能发现任何心脏异常或心脏病的痕迹。然而，他仍然将比尔的死判定为急性心律失常。该病理学家后来反思道，
it probably should have twigged to me that something wasn't right. Given hindsight, I suspect that he was the victim of foul play. I could have done things differently, but I can't change it now. And as far as I'm concerned, given the information I had at the time, I did the best I could. Bill Harrison's cause of death has since been changed from natural to unknown. In relation to Bridget Harrison's case, the independent review concluded. In hindsight, the circumstances and post-mortem findings which indicated evidence of possible strangulation may have been sufficient cause for the case to be considered a suspected homicide. It was recommended that a homicide detective review all sudden deaths to ensure no homicides
“我当时可能应该意识到有些不对劲。事后看来，我怀疑他是谋杀的受害者。我本可以采取不同的做法，但我现在无法改变了。就我而言，根据我当时掌握的信息，我已经尽力了。”比尔·哈里森的死因已从自然死亡改为未知。关于布里奇特·哈里森的案件，独立审查得出结论：事后看来，显示可能存在勒死迹象的情况和尸检结果，可能足以将该案视为疑似他杀。建议由凶杀案侦探审查所有猝死案件，以确保未来不会遗漏任何凶杀案。
would be missed in the future. The report stated, at no time does a police officer wish to be involved in an investigation that fails to uncover the truth. The trauma that the Harrison family's loved ones endured over the years was acknowledged, but for them, it was too little, too late. Bridget Harrison's brother stated, my faith in justice has been destroyed. Melissa Merritt and Chris Futore's four children are set to grow up with both of their parents behind bars. Caleb Harrison's son and daughter are left without their father or paternal grandparents. A former neighbour of the Harrison family told the Mississauga News,
报告指出：“警察绝不希望参与未能揭露真相的调查。”哈里森家族亲人多年来承受的创伤得到了承认，但对他们来说，这太少、太晚了。布里奇特·哈里森的兄弟说：“我对正义的信仰已被摧毁。”梅丽莎·梅里特和克里斯·福托雷的四个孩子注定要在父母双双入狱的情况下长大。凯莱布·哈里森的儿子和女儿失去了父亲和祖父母。哈里森家族的一位前邻居告诉《密西沙加新闻》：
those of us who've been around for years know what the kids have already been through. They've had way too much for their very young lives. Many have reported on the love Caleb Harrison had for his children and how he wanted them to succeed in life. He had said to others that it was his children that got him through his deep depression following his parents' deaths. He had both their names tattooed on his chest over his heart. Caleb's obituary read, Caleb found his true calling when he became a father. His fierce devotion to his children impressed all of us who watched him grow up.
“我们这些住了多年的人都知道孩子们已经经历了什么。在他们非常年轻的生命中，承受了太多。许多人报道了凯莱布·哈里森对孩子的爱，以及他希望他们能在生活中取得成功。他曾对别人说，是他的孩子们让他度过了父母去世后的深度抑郁。他在心脏上方的胸口纹了他们的名字。凯莱布的讣告写道：‘凯莱布在成为父亲时找到了他真正的人生使命。他对孩子们的强烈奉献精神打动了所有看着他长大的人。’
We all know that he's reunited with his loving parents, Bill and Bridget, in heaven. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们都知道他在天堂与他慈爱的父母比尔和布里奇特团聚了。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。